at the end of the war in iraq
an american soldier made a phone call to
his parents
hi mom and dad he said they'll be
sending me home in a few days
when i get home you think i could stay
with you guys for a while
his parents were overjoyed at the news
he would be coming home
of course cried his father you can live
with us for as long as you like
one of my buddies here has no place to
go he said
would you mind if he came to stay with
us for a while too that's fine son
said his mother your friends are always
welcome in our house
but there's something you should know
said the sun
my buddy stepped on a landmine
he uh he lost his arms and legs
there was a long silence on the other
end of the line
well that would be fine for a few days
said his mother but caring for a
disabled person is hard
it would be a big burden on your father
and i
perhaps you could find him a nursing
home or some sort of veterans hospital
instead
without another word the son hung up the
phone
the next day the parents received a
phone call from their son's commanding
officer
he regretfully informed them that their
son had committed suicide
the parents were devastated a few days
later
their son's corpse was flown back to the
usa and his parents were there to
collect the body
when they opened the coffin and saw
their son
they both broke down crying